the veil has been lifted on Val the
mysterious MCU figure gets grounded in
Black Panther wakanda forever here's how
the sequel helps set up a new Squad of
anti-heroes phase 4 of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has largely occupied
itself with reshuffling the pack many of
the heroes who survived the infinity
Saga became respected Elder superhero
Statesman and new Heroes and Legacy
characters like Elena Bulova and Kate
Bishop emerged among the more
interesting phase 4 Rivals is Contessa
Valentina Allegra de Fontaine AKA Val
don't call me that copy the Contessa is
a mysterious figure who's waltzed across
various movies and Disney Plus shows
like Nick Fury back in the day Kevin
feige himself confirmed early on that
bal's various appearances are indeed
building towards something and that
something has since turned out to be the
new superhero team in the MCU provided
that you want to call the antagonist
build Thunderbolts lineup heroes in the
classic sense of the word the main
difference between Nick Fury and the
Contessa is of course that everyone
knows who Fury is while Val has gone
through some pains to keep everything
but her full name and title of nobility
hidden from the viewer affable as she
may seem she's clearly tough as nails
and just ominous enough that you can't
be quite sure whether she's a hero or a
villain black panther wakanda forever
continues Val's Patchwork Storyline by
finally revealing something concrete
about the mysterious Contessa the
viewers find out that she's the director
of the mcu's version of the CIA and the
ex-wife of the previously most prominent
agency character Everett Ross this
explains a lot about's actions over the
course of phase 4 and how she has the
sway and know-how to pull her power
moves over the various super people
we've seen so far most importantly black
panther wakanda forever finally reveals
in no uncertain terms just how Val will
be able to start the Thunderbolts We're
not gonna need a Captain America
[Music]
we're gonna need
a US agent wakanda forever makes clear
that unlike the high-tech super-powered
world of Nick Fury's Shield the CIA is a
far more mundane and secretive spook
show and its director reflexes while
Fury is basically a superhero himself
Val seems to prefer classic behind the
scenes Espionage methods and deceptively
easy banter that hides her true
intentions she's so good at this that
she runs rings around Everett Ross who
not only knows Val very well but is also
a highly capable CIA operative himself
Mal's Connections in position as the CIA
director put her in the perfect place to
seek out and put together a team like
the Thunderbolts
depending on how you want to view it she
definitely seems practical or amoral
enough to Tinker with a lineup that
consists of antagonists and gray area
players like the Winter Soldier Elena
Bulova us agent Red Guardian ghost and
Taskmaster with the agency's assets at
her disposal she also has little problem
tracking them down as for who may very
well appear in the Thunderbolts movie
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross Val has
connections to him as well even if the
high-ranking general and secretary of
state would somehow have managed to
avoid the director of the CIA in a
professional context the fact that
Everett and Thaddeus have both been
affiliated with the Joint
counter-terrorist Center pretty much
guarantees that Alan Thunderbolt have
run into each other at some point it's
hard to think of a better position for
Val than the head of the CIA and now
that black panther wakanda forever lets
a cat out of the bag and it'll be
interesting to see how she wields her
considerable power hey she could even
turn out to be a scroll or Madam Hydra
like in the comics I'll surprised
whatever rossby
[Music]